Gauge rulers were invented to eliminate
the multiplication and division
and any errors that can occur.
Use the ruler that's appropriate
for your marked stitch and row section.
To determine the stitches,
use the side of the ruler marked S,
and place it between the markers,
and read from the ruler
from right to left.
Now, remember, we're measuring the columns
of stitches between the markers.
Measuring over 30 stitches,
my gauge ruler indicates that I have 14.
5 to 15 stitches
per 4 inches or 10 centimeters.
Measure the rows with the
gauge ruler the same way.
Be sure to flip the ruler
over and use the R side.
Again, be sure to measure the entire
stitch of both the starting and the ending
row between those marker rows.
Just picture if you have taken off those
marker rows, you want to do
the loops on both edges.
You want to get all of that whole section.
The ruler confirms that measuring over 40
rows, we have 22 stitches
to 4 inches or 10 centimeters.
These are the numbers we'll use to
calculate our pattern or to match gauge.
These are the critical numbers
to making sure that what you knit
ends up being the right size.
Gauge rulers, regular rulers, either way,
do your best to measure
correctly the first time.